Russia's Flagship talk show 60 Minutes
discussing Joe Biden's trip to Key a
host Olga scope asks if Russia
guaranteed his safety and if so why
we could have killed Biden but that
would have been too much her guest
replies
we spoke to Sergey Markov a one-time
advisor to President Putin just after he
came off the show
with Russia because the visit to avoid
nuclear war it was about not killing
John president of United States Joe
Biden from Russian rocket missiles
um if you uh this would have meant
potential nuclear war if anything had
happened to him
uh he has one of the possibility of the
killing president United States or
president of Russia that it can lead to
the nuclear war
no comment yet from the Kremlin but this
is a week pact with presidential
speeches there is plenty of time and
these pictures will be spun to further
the kremlin's narrative that Ukraine
does Joe Biden's bidding and that the
Real Enemy here is the United States
no doubt the symbolism of this trip is
not lost on Vladimir Putin but unlike
this time a year ago he understands now
there is no quick win to this war he's
seen the shape of Ukrainian bravery and
of its allies resolve in money and tanks
and sanctions and it hasn't stopped him
yet so Minister China's top Diplomat was
in Hungary today ahead of a trip to
Moscow the Kremlin says he may meet the
president after the U.S warned China
against supplying military aid to
support Putin's war effort China has not
so far but if it does this terrible war
in Europe could become more dangerous
still
Diana Magnus Sky News Moscow